so recently professor bowley showed us
log tables how in the good old days he
used to use books like this
to do big calculations i'd suggest
having a look at the video before
watching this one if you need to get up
to speed
but at the end of the last one we
promised we'd talk about how these
tables were created
now the log tables we were looking at
were in base 10 all numbers were sort of
converted to a power of 10 but that's
not how the first tables were created
that's what we're going to explain now
it's some pretty hardcore number
crunching at times but it is amazing to
think all those years ago
people were doing that kind of work to
pave the way for the scientists and
mathematicians in the years to come
now you're going to ask the question
where do these numbers come from how did
i make up tables anti-logarithms and
logarithms and this was done by a man
called john napier
in the period between 1594 and 1614.
this is before
calculus before newton's works before
leibniz before gauss all these great
mathematicians he was the one who did
the first bit which was to work out this
new function the logarithm and although
i've told you about logarithms to base
10 you could do logarithms to whatever
number it doesn't have to be
10 to the power it could be 3 to the
power or 5 to the power whatever you
want or 0.3 to the power so i'm going to
make up a number and show you the method
used by john napier so you can follow
the logic but i'm not going to ask you
to take 20 years which is what he took
in order to create the table i'm going
to make a very short abbreviated table
the number i am going to use which i
call a is a very strange number it's 1
minus
0.1 to the power of 10. that's our bases
that's going to be the base and it makes
the calculation as easy as possible and
i'll try to explain why so now i i want
to work out this number
to the power of 0.1
now 0.1 is different from 1 and 2 and 3
because it's got a decimal point and
once you've understood that you can get
decimal points out of this you can see
how you can build up a longer table and
this is
1 minus 0.1 to the 10
to the power of 0.1 which is 1 minus 0.1
10 times 0.1
is 1. so this is
0.9 0.9
is this number this exponent to the
power of 0.1
if i were to do this again
and put in 0.2
to the power of 10 times 0.2 which is 1
minus 0.1 to the power of 2
and now i have a choice here i'm going
to use this result
0.9 into 1 minus 0.1 because 0.9 minus
0.09
equals
0.81
so i've got the next one and you see i'm
doing it all the time by subtracting
this from that this is a this is tedious
oh
yeah he took 20 years over this and he
used a much larger number than this i
just do one more 0.81 minus 0.081
equals 0.729
and it goes on and on and on this is
working out things which i can put in a
table so this is just the same as i was
explaining when doing the log tables
this is just to a different base now
napier
used the number
1 minus 1 over 10 to the 7
to the power of 10 to the seven
that was his base that was the one he
used over a long period to get his
accurately as possible so he was using
this process
but with a more complicated number those
tables you were using as a boy in school
were base 10 what's going on here oh
there was a man called briggs who worked
out that if you calculated it to the
base e or to to this base you could
convert it to base 10 and that sold the
product much more easily because people
are used to dealing base 10 and there's
a simple transformation once you've got
one function
the exponential function rising up or
any number to some power rising up you
can convert to base 10 and that's what
briggs did and that helped sell the
product
so
napier did all the donkey work briggs
came in and got all the glory at the end
if you go through this algebra and you
get to
really long numbers you have problems
because first of all if i get eight
decimal places
and have to subtract off another eight
i'm bound to make mistakes
and people did make mistakes
and also if you get up to ten to the
seven decimal places
you really ought to be truncating at
some point because you can't do the sums
and so they were errors introduced
because people were doing subtraction
all the time and so
one of the great problems was to remove
all the errors from the tables because
if you're an astronomer and you're
relying on all these things to get
accurate measurements and accurate
calculations what you should see
it might disagree with the experiment
not because of
the experiment and the theory not
working but because the calculations are
wrong based on these tables and so
somebody called babbage
tried to invent a difference engine to
try and remove all the errors in all the
mathematical tables and couldn't do it
you